All right now I thought I'd begin today.
This is by the way,
a regular practice.
Um,
this is as close as I get to
bulleted PowerPoint. It's all there.
I ought to have got through those
topics by the end of the lecture.
If I don't,
not to worry,
I'll pick up wherever the dotted line
emerges a in the subsequent lecture.
But in any case,
I thought I'd begin today by making a few
remarks about the title of our course,
uh, because it has some big words
in it, theory and literature,
but also introduction.
I think it's worth saying a word or two
about the word introduction as well.
Uh,
now theory has a very complicated Adam
illogical history that I won't trouble
you with.
Uh,
the trouble with the atomology of theory
and the way in which the word has been
used traditionally is that sometimes
it actually means practice. And then,
uh,
at other historical periods it means
something very different from practice.
Something typically from which
practice is derived. Well,
that's the sense of theory that
I, I like to work with. Um,
and I would pause over it
by saying that after all,
there is a difference and we should
and we shouldn't too quickly at least
confused the terms. There's a difference
between theory and methodology.
Yes,
it's probably fair enough to say
that methodology is applied theory.
Um,
but there's a great danger and supposing
that every aspect of theory has an
immediate application theory is very
often a purely speculative undertaking.
Uh,
it's an hypothesis about something
the exact nature of which one needn't
necessarily having view.
It's a supposition that uh,
whatever the object of theory might be,
it must,
owing to whatever intellectual constraints
one can imagine be of such a form and
at this level of abstraction plainly,
um, there isn't all that much,
uh,
incentive to apply thinking of that kind.
But on the other hand,
undoubtedly theory does exist for the
most part to be applied very frequently.
Courses of this kind have a text,
uh,
listen to us, the rime of the
ancient mariner, a short story.
And then once in a while they
disquisition of the lecturer will pause,
the text will be produced and whatever
theory has recently been talked about
will be applied to the text so that
you'll get a post colonial reading of the
rime of the ancient mariner
something by the way,
which is absolutely fascinating
and important to do. Uh, and uh,
so on through the course.
Now I suppose it's my, uh,
reluctance,
um,
to get into the intricacies of questions
having to do with applied theory that
makes me prefer to keep it simple.
Our text is a story for toddlers
called Tony The tow truck.
I've decided not to pass it
out today because after all,
I want to get it into the right hands.
You can't read it unless you take the
course. Uh, and, and so, you know,
I'm going to wait a little bit. We
don't, we don't come back to it, um,
at least for the moment. And, uh, but
you see that it's mercifully short.
Um,
and as time passes,
we will do some rather
interesting tricks with it.
We will revert as others revert
to listen to us, to Donner,
the tow truck for the purpose of
introducing questions of applied theory.
Now this may suggest a
certain condescension both
toward theory and toward
literary texts, uh, which
is not at all intended.
It's much more a question
of reminding that, uh,
reminding you that if you can do it with
this, you can do it with anything. Uh,
but also of reminding you that
after all reading, reading,
just anything,
um,
is a complex and potentially
almost unlimited activity.
That's one of the good things,
uh,
that theory teaches us and that I hope
to be able to get across, uh, in our,
in the, in the course of our, of, of,
of our varied approaches to Tony,
the tow truck.
Now theory resembles philosophy perhaps
in this that it asks fundamental
questions and also at
times builds systems.
That is to say theory has
certain ambitions to a
total ization of what can be
thought, ah, that resembles
our rival's philosophy.
But theory differs from philosophy.
And this is something that I'm
going to be coming back to, uh,
presents tingly in the set in the second
half of this lecture and many times
hereafter theory difference from most
philosophy in that involves a certain,
and this is by no means self evident.
Why should this be,
is one of the questions
we're going to be asking.
It involves a certain skepticism.
There seems to be a doubt of a variety
of doubts about the foundations of what
we can think about the basis of
our opinions that pervades theory,
uh, seen some horror and other
to characterize its history. Now,
not all theory that we read in
this course is skeptical. Uh,
some of the most powerful and profound
thought that's been devoted to the
subject of theory of
literature, uh, is positive, uh,
in its intentions and in its
views. But by and large, you will,
uh, happily or unhappily, uh,
come to terms with the fact that much
of what you're going to be reading this
semester is under girded
or perhaps I should say,
undermined by this persisting skepticism.
It's crucial as I say, and I'm going
to become back coming back to it,
but it's just the point I want to make
in passing about the nature of theory.
Now turning to the word literature,
this is not theory of relativity,
theory of music, theory of government.
This is of course in theory of literature
and theory of literature shares in
common with other kinds of
literature, uh, other kinds of theory.
The need for definition that is to say
maybe the most central and for me and for
me possibly the most fascinating
question theory asks as well,
what is literature?
How do we know it when we see it?
How can we define it?
Now,
much of what we'll be reading
takes up the question,
what is literature and provides
us with fascinating, uh,
and all was for the moment,
I think enticing definitions.
There are definitions based on
form, circularity, symmetry,
economy of form, lack of
economy, of form, repetition.
There are definitions based
on psychological complexity,
psychological balance,
psychological harmony,
sometimes psychological inbounds
and disharmony. And they're also,
they're also definitions which,
which insists that somehow there's
an epistemological difference between
literature.
And other kinds of utterance,
whereas most utterances purport to be
saying something true about the actual
state of things in the world.
Uh,
literary utterance is
under no such obligation.
The argument goes and OT properly to be
understood as fiction making it up as
opposed to referring.
All right?
Now all of these definitions have had
currency will be going over them again.
Uh, and I, and, and, and finding them,
I hope more fascinating as
we learn more about them.
But at the same time, even as I
rattle off this list of possibilities,
probably you felt yourself an
upsurge of capitalism is ed,
right? Goodness. I can easily find
exceptions to all those rules.
It's ridiculous to think that literature
could be defined in any one of those
ways or even in a combination of all
of them. Literature is many things,
a many splendid thing you say to yourself,
and it simply cannot be confined or
trapped within a definition of that kind.
Well in good, properly ecumenical
of you. But at the same time,
it gives rise to a sense
that possibly after all,
literature just isn't anything at all.
In other words,
that literature may not be susceptible
of definition of any one definition,
but it is rather, and this is the
so called neo pragmatist argument,
but it is whatever you think it is or
more precisely whatever your interpretive
community sense that it is.
And this isn't really a big problem.
It's kind of unsettling because
we like to know what things are,
but at the same time,
it's not really a big problem because as
long as we know about the fact that lit
that a certain notion of literature
exists in certain communities,
we can begin to do very interesting
work precisely with that idea.
And we can say there's a great deal to
learn about what people think literature
is and we can develop very
interesting kinds of thinking, uh,
about the variety of ways in which these,
uh,
in which these ideas are,
are expressed.
And so it's not perhaps crippling
if this is the conclusion we reach.
But at the same time,
it's not the only possible conclusion.
Possibility of definition presents a
definition is important to us and we're
certainly not going to give it
short shrift in this course.
We're going to make every
effort to define literature, uh,
as carefully as we can. Now, in
addition to defining literature,
literary theory also asks questions,
obviously not unrelated,
but which open up the field somewhat
what causes literature and what are the
effects of literature.
And in a way there's a subset of questions
that arises from those to the effect.
And this is of course what we'll be
taking up next time. The question,
what is an author? That is to say
if something causes literature, um,
there must be some sort of
authority behind it. Uh,
and therefore we find ourselves
asking what is an author?
And by the same token,
if literature has affects,
it must have effects on someone.
And this gives rise to the equally
interesting and vaccine question.
What is a reader?
And literary theory is very much
involved with questions of that kind.
Uh,
and organizing those
questions is basically what
rationalizes the structure of
our syllabus.
You'll notice that we move in the syllabus
after a couple of introductory, uh,
talks that I'll be that
I'll mention in a minute.
We move in the syllabus from the idea
that literature is in some sense caused by
language to the idea that literature is
in some sense caused by the human psyche
to the idea that literature is in some
sense caused by social economic and
historical forces. And there
are corollaries, uh, for the,
for those ideas in terms of the kinds of
effects that literature has and what we
might imagine ourselves to
conclude from them. And finally,
literary theory asks one other
important question asked many,
but this is the way,
at least I'm organizing it for today.
It asks one other important question,
the one with which we will actually begin.
Not so much what is a reader,
but how does reading get done?
That is to say,
how do we form the conclusion that we
are interpreting something adequately,
that we have a basis for the
kind of reading that we're doing?
What is the reading experience like?
Uh,
how do we meet the text face to face?
How do we put ourselves
in touch with the text,
which may after all in a variety
of ways be remote from us? Now,
these are the questions that are
asked by what's called hermeneutics.
Uh, a difficult word that we
will be taking up next week. Um,
it has to do with the god Hermes who
conveyed language to man and a certain
sense among many other functions,
the god of communication. Uh,
and it is after all obviously,
uh, about communication.
So hermeneutics will be
our first topic and it's,
and it attempts to answer the
last question that I'll mention,
which is raised by theory of literature.
All right?
Now let me pause quickly
over the word introduction.
I first started teaching this course
in the late seventies and eighties when
literary theory,
it was a thing absolutely of the
moment as I told the teaching fellows.
Um,
I had a colleague in those days who looked
at me enviously and said he wished he
had the black leather
concession at the door.
Theory was both hot and cool,
and it was something about which following
from that one had not just opinions,
but very, very strong
opinions. In other words,
the teaching fellows I had in those days,
who knows,
they may rise up against me
in the same way this semester,
but the teaching fellows
I had in those days said,
you can't teach an introduction.
You can't teach a survey.
You can't say if it's Tuesday, it must
be full cove. It's if it's Thursday,
it must be locked calm.
You can't approach theory that way.
Theory is important and it's important
to know what you believe. In other words,
what the basis of all other
possible theories. I'm a feminist.
I'm an Acadian.
I'm a student of Paul demonn.
I believe that these are the foundational
moments of theorizing and that if
you're going to teach
anything like a survey,
you've got to derive the rest of it
from whatever the moment I happen to
subscribe to my be.
All right.
That's the way it felt to
teach theory in those days.
It was awkward teaching an introduction
and privately for that reason,
while I was teaching lit 300,
which was called lit,
why Paul Newman was teaching z.
He was,
he was teaching a lecture course
nearby. Uh, not at the same time,
uh,
which was interpretation as practiced by
the school the month that was let z and
it did indeed apply imply
every other form of theory. Uh,
and it was extremely
rigorous and interesting,
but it wasn't a survey it took
for granted, in other words,
that everything else would
derive from the fundamental idea.
But it didn't for a minute think that a
whole series of fundamental ideas could
share space,
could be a kind of smorgasbord
that you could mix and match and,
and I kind of happy go,
go lucky eclectic way,
which perhaps we will be seeming to do
from time to time in our introductory
course.
Well now do one,
does one feel any nostalgia for the
coolness and heat of this moment?
Yes and no. Uh, it was
fascinating to be, uh,
as Wordsworth says, bliss was it in that
dawn to be alive. It was fascinating, uh,
to be around in those days.
But at the same time,
I think it's rather advantageous
for us to be still in theory.
That is to say we still have views.
We still have to recognize that what
we think derives from this or that
understanding of theory and these or those
theoretical principles and we have to
understand the way in which what we do
and say what we write in our papers and
articles is grounded in
theoretical premises,
which if we don't come to terms with them,
we will simply naively reproduce without
being fully aware of how we're using
them and how indeed they're using us.
And so it is as crucial as
ever to understand theory.
At the same time,
we have the vantage point of I
suppose what we can now call history.
Some of what we'll be studying is no
longer practiced as that which is the
absolutely necessary
central path to methodology.
Some of what we're studying has
had its moment of flourishing,
has remain influential as a paradigm
that shapes other paradigms but is not
itself perhaps today.
The paradigm which gives
us the opportunity of
historical perspective so that
from time to time during the course
of the course of you're trying to say
something about why certain theoretical
issues and ideas pushed themselves into
prominent at certain historical moments.
And that too then can become
part of our enterprise.
So an introduction is not only valuable
for those of us who simply wished to
acquire knowledge,
it's also a valuable,
I think in lending and
additional perspective to
the topic of theory and to an
understanding about how
theory is on the one hand,
perhaps in a certain sense now,
uh,
and historical topic and
is on the other hand,
something that we're very much
engaged in and still committed to.
So all that then by way of rationale
for teaching and introduction to theory.
Right now the question, how
does the history of, uh,
how does literary theory relate
to the history of criticism?
Not this is a course that
I like to teach to, uh,
usually teach it Plato to ts Elliot or
Plato to Iaa Richards or some sort of
important figure in the
early 20th century. Uh,
and it's a course which is absolutely
fascinating and all sorts of ways.
And it has one very important thing in
common with literary theory that is to
say literary criticism is to perpetually
concerned with the definition of
literature.
Many of the issues that I raised in
talking about defining literature are as
relevant for literary criticism
as they are for literary theory.
And yet we all instinctively know that
these are two very different enterprises.
Literary theory loses something that
literary criticism just takes for granted.
Literary theory is not concerned with
issues of evaluation and it's not really
concerned with concomitant
issues of appreciation.
Literary theory just takes
those for granted as part
of the the sense experience
as one might say,
uh,
of any reader and prefers rather to
dwell on questions of description,
analysis and speculation.
As I've said.
Now that's what's lost in theory,
but what's new in theory.
And here I come to the topic which will
occupy most of my attention for the
remainder of the lecture.
What's new in theory is the element of
skepticism that literary criticism by and
large, which is usually affirming
a canon of some sort, uh,
doesn't reflect literary theory as I say,
is skeptical about the
foundations of its subject matter.
And also in many cases about the
foundations of what it itself is doing.
So the question is,
how on earth did this come about?
It's an historical question,
as I say,
and I want to devote the
rest of the lecture to it.
Why should doubt about the veridical
or truth affirming possibilities of
interpretation be so
widespread in the 20th century?
Now here a big glop of
intellectual history.
I think it arises from what one might
call and what often is called modernity.
Not to be confused with modernism
and early 20th century phenomenon,
but a the history of modern thought as
it usually derives from the generation of
Descartes, Shakespeare, Cervantes. Notice
something about all of those figures.
Shakespeare is preoccupied with
figures who may or may not be crazy,
so Ivantis is preoccupied
with a figure who is crazy.
We're pretty sure of that,
but he certainly is it.
He takes it for granted that he is
the most rational and systematic of,
of, of all thinkers and
raises questions about,
since we all take ourselves to be rational
to raises questions about just how we
know ourselves, not to be paranoid
delusive like Don Quixote.
And so that too can be unsettling when
we think of this as happening at a
certain contemporary and contemporaneous
moment in the history of thought,
not Descartes.
You remember in his meditations
begins by asking a serious cause,
a series of questions about
how we can know anything.
And one of the skeptical questions he
asks is, well, might I not be crazy?
In other words, Descartes is still
thinking along these same lines. He says,
well, maybe I've been seized
by an evil genius of some kind.
Or maybe I'm just crazy. Now
why? And here's the question,
why do we get this nervousness about
the relationship between what I know and
how I know it arising at this moment?
Well,
I think it's characterized,
at least in part by what Descartes
goes on to say in his meditations,
Descartes' settles the matter,
perhaps somewhat sweeping
the question whether a,
he's crazy under the rug because I still
not sure he answers that question. Uh,
but he settles them at the
matter of famously by saying,
I think therefore I am.
And furthermore,
as a concomitant,
I think therefore all the things that
I'm thinking about can be understood to
exist as well. Now, the
Cartesian Revolution,
uh,
establishes something that is
absolutely crucial for what we call the
enlightenment of the next hundred,
hundred 50 years. In other words,
the idea that there is a distance between
the mind and the things that it thinks
about, but that this distance
is a good thing. In other words,
if you look too closely at a picture
or if you stand too far away from it,
you don't see it clearly,
it's out of focus.
But if you achieve just
the right distance from it,
it comes into focus and the idea
of scientific object objectivity,
the idea that motivates the creation of
the great encyclopedia by the figures of
the French enlightenment.
This idea all arises out of the idea
that is a certain appropriate objective
distance between the perceiver
and the perceived gradually.
However,
the idea that this distance is
not too great begins to erode.
So that in 1796 Kahn who isn't exactly
enlisted on the side of the skeptics by
most of his serious students,
nevertheless does say something
equally famous as that,
as that which Descartes said,
and a good deal more disturbing.
We cannot know the thing
in itself. Now, as I said,
con erected such an incredibly magnificent
scaffolding around the thing in
itself. That is to say the variety of
ways in which, although we can't know it,
we can sort of triangulate it
and come to terms with it. Oh,
bleakly that it seems churlish to
enlist him on the side of the skeptics.
But at the same time,
there's a sense of a danger in the
distance between subject and object that
begins to emerge.
In thinking of this kind now by 1807
Hagle and the phenomenology of mind is
saying that in recent history and in
recent developments of consciousness,
something unfortunate has set in,
we have unhappy consciousness,
unhappy consciousness,
which is the result of
estrangements and Frendo,
which drives us too far away from
the thing that we're looking at.
We are no longer certain at
all of what we're looking at.
And consciousness therefore
feels alienated. All right?
So you can already began to see a
development in intellectual history that
perhaps opens the way
to a certain skepticism.
But the crucial thing hasn't
yet happened because after all,
in all these accounts,
even that of Hagle,
there's no doubt about the authority of
consciousness to think what it thinks.
It may not clearly think
about things about objects,
but it has a kind of legitimate basis
that that generates the sort of thinking
that it does.
But then,
and here's where I want you to look at
the passages that I've handed out the
here's where, uh, three great
figures, there are others,
but these are considered the salmon will
figures begin to raise questions which
complicate the whole
issue of consciousness.
Their argument is it's not just that
consciousness doesn't clearly understand
what it's looking at. It's also, and,
and is therefore alienated from it.
It's also that consciousness is alienated
from its own underpinnings that it
doesn't have any clear sense of where
it's coming from any more than what it's
looking at and other eds.
That consciousness is not
only a strange from the world,
but that it is in and
of itself in authentic.
So I'll just quickly look at
these passages. Marks is a,
in the famous argument about commodity
fetishism and capital is comparing the
way in which we take the product of human
labor and turn it into a commodity by
saying that it has objective value by
saying that we know what its value is in
and of itself, he compares that with
religion. The argument is, well,
God is a product of human labor.
In other words,
it's not a completely supercilious
argument, you know? I mean,
so God has brought into
being the same way.
Objects that we make use of are brought
into being God is a product of human
labor,
but then we turn around and we say God
exists and has value objectively marks.
His argument is that
the two forms of belief,
belief in the objective value of the
commodity and belief in God are the same.
Now, whether or not any of
this is true, believe me,
is neither here nor there.
The point that Marx is making,
the point that Marx is
making is that consciousness.
That is to say the way in which we
believe things is determined by factors
outside its control.
That is to say in the case
of Marx's arguments, social,
historical and economic factors that
determine what we think and and and which
in general we call ideology.
That is to say ideology is driven by
factors beyond the Ken of the person who
thinks a ideologically. So you'll
see the problem for consciousness.
Now it's not just a single
problem, it's two fold. It's,
it's inauthentic relationship with
the things that looks at and also it's
inauthentic relationship
with its own underpinnings.
The argument is exactly the same for
Nicha only he shifts the ground of attack
for nature.
The underpinnings of consciousness which
make the operations of consciousness in
authentic, uh, are the
nature of language itself.
That is to say that when we
think we're telling the truth,
we're actually using worn
out figures of speech.
What then is truth,
a mobile army of metaphors,
but Tonomys anthropomorphism in short
of some of human relations which became
poetically and rhetorically intensified
a et Cetera, et Cetera, et Cetera,
and now no longer and are now
no longer have a count as coins,
but our debates now,
that word now is very important.
It's suggests that nature does somehow
believe that there's a privileged moment
in the history of language when perhaps
language is a truth serum when it is
capable of telling the truth.
But language has now simply be become
a question of worn out figures,
all of which dictates what
we believe to be true.
I speak, uh, of, you
know, I, I, I speak, uh,
in a figurative way about the relationship
between the earth and the sky.
And I believe that there's a sky.
God I speak because I simply don't
believe that I'm using figures of speech.
All of this is implied in niches
argument. In other words, language,
the nature of language,
the way language is received by us in
turn determines what we can do with it,
which is to say determines what we think.
So that is so that for nature,
the distortion of truth,
that is to say the distortion of the
power to observe in consciousness has as
its underlying cause language,
the state of language,
the status of language.
Freud finally argues for exactly the
same relationship between consciousness.
That is to say what I think I am
thinking from minute to minute and the
unconscious,
which perpetually in one way or another
unsettles what I'm thinking and saying
from minute to minute. You know that in
the psychopathology of everyday life, uh,
Freud reminded us that the Freudian
slip isn't something that happens just
sometimes. And nobody knows better than
those, knows this better than a lecturer.
It's something that happens all
the time and the and and the fruit.
The Freudian slip is something that one
lives with simply as a phenomenon of the
slippage of consciousness under
the influence of the unconscious.
Now in the passage I gave you,
Freud says very interesting thing,
which is that after all,
we have absolutely no objective
evidence that the unconscious exists.
You know, I mean the unconscious,
if I could see the unconscious,
that it'd be conscious,
right?
The unconscious Freud is
saying is something that we
have to infer from the way
consciousness operates.
We've got to infer something.
We've got to figure out somehow how it
is that consciousness is never completely
inhibited, never completely does,
and says what it wants to say.
So the spin on consciousness
for Freud is the unconscious.
Now someone who didn't fully believe Marx,
Nietzsche and Freud,
a very important modern philosopher in
the hermaneutic tradition named Paul
Ricoeur famously said in the forest
passage on your sheet that these great
precursors of modern thought
and particularly I would
immediately add of modern
literary theory together
dominate a school of suspicion.
There is an other words in recurs view,
a hermeneutics of suspicion and skepticism
or suspicion is a word that count
also bay appropriated perhaps more
rigorously for philosophy as negativity.
That is to say whatever seems manifest
or obvious or patent in what we're
looking at is undermined for
this kind of mind by a negation,
which is counterintuitive. That
is to say, which would seem, uh,
not just not just to qualify what we
understand ourselves to be looking at,
but to undermine it altogether.
And these tendencies in the way in
which Mark's nature and Freud had been
received. And when we read food
coast, what does an author,
and next time we'll return to this
question of how Marx, Nietzsche,
and Freud have been received and what we
should make of that in view of glucose
idea. That there's, well, you know, not
that there's no such thing as an author,
but that it's rather dangerous to
believe that there are authors, well,
if it's dangerous to believe that
there are others. What about Marx?
Nietzsche and Freud Fuko confronts,
uh,
this question in what is an author,
and gives us some interesting
results of his thinking for us.
The aftermath,
a particular even prefer precisely
of the passages I've just quoted,
but certainly of the earth of the three
authors I've quoted from a can it to a
large degree,
the understood as
accounting for the topic,
the phenomenon of literary theory
as we study it. In other words,
literary theory because of the
influence of these figures, uh, is, uh,
to a considerable degree a hermeneutics
of suspicion recognized as such,
both by its, uh, proponents.
And famously, I think, uh,
this is perhaps what is
historical for you by its enemies.
During the same period when I was
first teaching this course, um,
a veritable six foot shelf of diatribes
against literary theory was being
written in the public's fear.
There was the most, I mean you can,
you can take or leave
literary theory fine,
but the idea that there would be such an
incredible outcry against it was one of
the most fascinating results of
it. That is to say for many, many,
many people,
literary theory had something to do with
the hand of civilization as we know it.
That's one of the things that seems
rather strange to us today from an
historical perspective,
but the found undermining
of foundational knowledge,
which seemed to be part and parcel of
so much that went on and literary theory
was seen as the central crucial threat
to rationality emanating from the academy
and was attacked, uh, in
those, in those terms.
And as I say,
at least six feet of lively polemics.
Uh, all of that is the legacy of
literary theory. And as I say,
uh, it arises in part from this element
of skepticism that I thought it,
uh, that I've thought it
best to emphasize today. Now,
I think that, excuse me, one thing,
recurrent leaves out and
something that will, that,
that we can anticipate as becoming more
and more important for literary theory
and other kinds of theory in
the 20th century as Darwin.
That is to say,
it strikes me that Darwin could
very easily be considered, uh,
a fourth hermeneutics of suspicion.
Of course Darwin,
Darwin was not interested in suspicion,
but he was certainly the founder of ways
of thinking about consciousness that
are determined, socio biologically
determined, determined,
and in the realm of cognitive science
determined as artificial intelligence and
so on.
All of this is Darwinian thinking and
I think increasingly will be central in
importance in the 21st
century. What, what,
what will alter the,
the shape of literary theory as it was
known and studied in the 20th century is
I think an increasing emphasis on
cognitive science and socio biological
approaches, both the literature and
to Interpretive Processes, uh, that,
uh,
will derive from Darwin.
And the same way that strands of thinking
of the 20th century derived from the
three figures that I've mentioned.
But what all this gives rise to.
And this brings me finally to the passages
which you have on both sides of your
sheet and which I don't
want to take up today,
but just to preview passages from James
Ambassadors 1903 and from checkoffs,
the Cherry Orchard 1904.
In other words,
I'm at pains to remind you that this is
a specific historical moment in which in
a variety of ways the speaker
argues that consciousness,
that is to say the feeling of being alive
and being someone acting in the world
no longer involves agency.
The feeling that somehow to be
conscious has become to be a puppet.
That there is a,
that,
that there is a limitation on what
we can do imposed by the idea that
consciousness is determined in
ways that we cannot control, uh,
and cannot get the better of.
So that a stressor in the ambassadors
and yet petered off in the Cherry Orchard
speak for a point of view,
which is a kind of partially well
informed gloom and doom that could be
understood to pervade, uh, texts
that are much better informed, uh,
that we will be considering.
But nevertheless are especially important
as an aspect of their historical
moment. And I want to begin the next
lecture, uh, by taking up those passages.
Please do bring them,
and I will also, uh, be,
be be passing around Tony the tow truck.
Uh,
and I'll give you a brief description
of what the little children's book
actually looks like. A, and then
we will plunge into the question,
what is an author?
So I'll see you on Thursday.